hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game and this one is from
round one of the super united rapid and
blitz tournament uh being played in
croatia it's already safiruja versus
even character one of the few players
that actually has a positive score
against magnus carlsen in classical
chess beating him uh in the 2014 trumps
olympiad and getting a draw in the 2015
tata tata steel masters edition uh and
also he's a part of magnus's team so
he's a very unpleasant opponent and it's
uh very interesting what um uh
well what uh alireza decides to play
against him uh so let's dive straight
into it the action in this game uh
happens way into the endgame but we're
gonna you know pretty much fly over
there right away so alireza has the
white pieces and he opens with e4 we
have pawn to c5 uh even pretty much
always plays the sicilian defense
against e4 knight to knight to f3 d6 and
now knight to c3 uh it's uh very
interesting that alireza avoids the open
sicilian as he is also
uh really really
sharp and can play pretty much anything
but i i think that's because um i even
is just so so well known for his uh
great skills in the sicilian he decides
to mix it up a bit and he employs a very
very rare line so knight to f6 and now
h3 uh h3 being the eighth most popular
reply to knight to f6 uh but it's still
not a new position we have pawn to e5
taking control over the d4 square bishop
to c4 and now the ship to e7 preparing
the castle uh we have d3 and here even
castle so and now uh there are a couple
of
games that reach this position but i
would play moves like bishop to a3 g5 a4
uh but here already has a place knight
to h2 and it is not as of move 7 that we
have a completely new game so quite
quite interesting
moving the knight over to g4 trying to
trade off some of the uh some of the
pieces so here we have knight to c6 even
continuous development knights to g4 and
now bishop to e6 offering a trade of
light square bishops knights the e3 now
if the bishops get traded off he can uh
put a knight on c4
and not knight to d4 uh we have castles
uh by white and now uh rook to b8
preparing to push the pawn to b5 so a4
preventing this and now a6 we have
knight c to d5 a very nice square for
the knight and now a pawn to b5 finally
advancing that pawn we have captures
captures and knight captures on f6
bishop captures and bishop to d5 saying
that if you capture here i'm gonna play
knight captures on d5 and have a monster
knight here for a very very long time so
even continues with b4 he doesn't want
to see c3 on the board but of course
that's exactly what alireza will play at
least now e1 will get a b file for his
rook so c3 b captures b captures and the
knight goes to b3 now attacks the rook
and the bishop so uh here we have bishop
captures on e6 a nice in between move f
captures and rook to b1 a nice capture
fest happening here knight captures on
c1 queen captures and now bishop to g5
pinning the knight here
we have rook to e1 and now comes queen
to f6 putting pressure on f2 now that
the rook
left the f1 square and now rook to b2
so you don't have to worry if the if the
rook captures queen will capture and the
queen will guard the f2 pawn we have h6
and now queen to c2 uh we have bishop
captures an e3 even trades of the bishop
for knight rook captures and rook
captures on b2 queen captures and now
queen to h4 again just putting pressure
on the f2 pawn and this is pretty much
very very drawish
even uh very nicely neutralized
alireza's threats we have rook back to
e1 and now king to h7 uh we have queen
to e2 uh and now rook to f6 we have rook
to a1 and now queen to f4 so just
keeping the the position very solid not
doing anything crazy c4 grabbing a
little more space in the center here and
rook to f7 not allowing rook to a7 uh it
doesn't do all that much but still no
reason to allow it g3 pushing the queen
back and now queen to f3 offering a
queen trade and there is really no good
way to continue uh other than going into
a rook and game so that's what alireza
does we have queen captures rook
captures and this is only move 31 uh but
alireza does not want to squander the
white pieces he will he will try and
push this we have rook to a3 uh
defending the pawn uh it's equal
material rook and game but the the one
thing that alireza has going for him is
that even has a double e pawn so maybe
he can use that to his advantage e
double pawns are very easy targets for
the rook so king the g6 we have came to
g2 attacking the rook rook f7 and now
rook to a6 going after the pawn here
rook to d7 defending and king to f3
activating the king king of six now
comes king to g4 now we have g6 cutting
off the white king h4 and now pawn to h5
pushing back how it is king king to f3
and king to e7
uh we have g4 h captures king captures
and now king to f6 so again this is a
dead draw but still there no reason to
call it a draw just yet
we've broke the b6 and now we have rook
to d8 rook to b7 and rook to a8 now uh
even shows that he's
also interested in continuing this game
we have rook to d7 now going after this
pawn and rook to a6 defending it with
king to f3 uh rook to b6 and now king
the e3 rook to a6 uh waiting to see what
all it is i will do we have f3 rook to
b6 and now king to d2 uh rook to b2 with
check and now king to c3 allowing the
rook to go after the kingside pawns rook
to f2 and now finally rook captures on
d6 so rook captures on f3 now rook c6 is
going after this pawn and rook to h3
going after the h pawn with rook
captures on c5 rook captures on h4 and
rook to c8 so again not all that much
has changed in the position we are just
getting closer to a draw uh or so you
would think we have g5 even starts
pushing his pass pawn and rook to g8 now
putting the rook behind the pass pawn we
have rook to h1 and now pawn to c5
alireza will now also start pushing his
pass pawn so even wants to be able to
deliver some checks from behind
rook to g1 we have king to b4 and now
king to f7 kicking the rook away from
the g file rook to h8 and rook to c1 now
not allowing further advancement of the
pawn so king to b5 rook to c3 and going
after the d3 pawn and now pawn to c6 uh
we have king to e7 now comes rook to h7
check king to d8 and rook the d7 with
check also now defending the d3 pawn
king the c8 and rook to d6 putting
pressure on the e6 pawn and now even
starts advancing the g pawn we have pawn
to g4
rook captures on e6 and now we have rook
captures on d3 rook captures on e5
already is now up upon
but
uh should not be a problem it's a very
very often that um a rook end game will
be a draw even if you are down upon if
your uh king is well positioned and here
iman's king is very well positioned
however you have to continue the game
properly and even was very low on time
here uh he pushed the pawn to g3 and now
the position is completely winning for
alireza just to give you an idea why
this is so uh you can play a move like
rook to e3 making it impossible for
alireza to move his rook to attack the
pawn uh
otherwise you're gonna capture this pawn
uh so so uh rook to e3 is one of the
moves you can play you could also play
rook to d1 this makes sense because if
rook to g5 going after the pawn you can
now play rook to g1 and now you will be
able to advance your pawn all the way
and then you will have the
well-known trick of delivering a check
and then promoting your pawn to a queen
if of course white allows it so the game
might continue something like e5 g3 e6
g2
rook the g8 to check and now king to c7
where we would either either see a
repetition with checks or rook the g7
check king to c8 e7 if white wanted to
push this rook to b1 with check king to
c5 and now you will just have to
continue checking the white king rook
the c1 with check if um uh
if uh
of course you are given one move then
maybe you can promote this pawn to a
queen but not really as you also have to
be very very careful of e8 check and
also the rook is guarding the g1 square
so probably king d5 rook d1 checking c5
and we will just be repeating this so
that's the other way to play this uh but
one thing you cannot do is the move that
even played and that is pawn to g3 and
of course even knows this but uh he was
very low on time uh and he allowed
alireza to now take uh advantage of the
position and alireza does he plays rook
to g5 and this is the only way to win
the game we have rook to e3 now going
after the pawn but now king to b6 now
all of the squares are covered in front
of the in front of the black king and we
are threatening checkmate so you have to
do something about this rook the b3
check king c5 and rook the c3 with check
we have king to d5 rook to d3 check king
to c4 now uh no more checks we have rook
to a3 and now how do you win this game
uh feel free to show us your endgame
prowess by pausing the video and winning
this game for alireza while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
this congratulations on being a true
master of the end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is rook the g7 we cut off the black king
from going after the pawn here and now
uh there is just nothing black can do
if even moves the rook uh from the third
rank then we're just going to play rook
captures and g3 and if he doesn't uh
there's really not uh well well there's
really not much to do aside from from
doing that if you try going after the
pawn we just
defended with the king if you go back
rook to a3 we start advancing this spawn
this pawn this spawn and there's really
no move for black to make so instead
rook to a1 was played even gave up the
pawn right away we have rook captures on
g3 and now king to c7 this way at least
you can activate your king from the back
rank rook to g6 and now rook to c1 with
check king d5 we have rook to d1 check
king the e5 rook to e1 and now rook to
e6
rook to h1 king to f6 not trying to uh
further advance the pawn and you want to
disrupt the to defend the c6 spawn rook
the h6 check king to f7 and now rook
back to h4 point is if you trade pawns
captures captures and king captures in
c6
of course the king is on e6 this is a
well-known winning position e5 if you
move the king just here the king
controls all of the squares you just
push the pawn and win the game so after
king f7 rook to h4 was played now comes
pawn to e5 we have rook to e4 king to f6
rook there for chuck king to g5 and now
rook back to f1
allowing white to move so rook to d6 and
now rook to f2 we have king to g6 rook
to f1 and now rook to d2
we have rook to e1 attacking the pawn
and now king to f6 rook to f1 check king
the e6 and rook to h1 now trying to
deliver some side checks uh but just
rook to c2 we have to defend this pawn
rook the h6 with check and king to f7
and now again you can capture the pawn
but it doesn't matter if you trade of
course the pass pawn is again winning
it's the exact same position or rather a
very similar one so rook h7 check we
have king to g6 rook h1 again alireza
wins the move pawn to e6 rook to g1 with
check king to f7 rook f1 check and king
to e8 we have rook to e1 and now pawn to
e7
so very little to do rook to f1 uh the
king seems to be cut off but now of
course we just counter that rook to h2
rook f3 now comes rook to d2 now we're
gonna go for this check rook to f1 and
rook to d7 with check king c8 we have
pawn to c7 and now there is no defense
against rook to d8 to check rook to h1
was played but just rook to d8 with
check king captures on c7 and now king
f7 and it was in this position on move
97 that even charis resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
once uh you give this check rook f1
checking g6 now you either continue
checking the white king and we zigzag
our way over to the to the black rook or
you put the rook behind the pawn but it
doesn't matter we just bring a queen
into the game and now this will of
course be winning as
uh rook and king always beat a king
very nicely done by alireza he in the
second round he got a draw against yani
ponishi and in the third round he
defeated the vessel into paulov uh
basically just crushed him it was it was
so crushing that i decided not even to
show the game it was uh so scary uh but
yeah here are the standings uh after the
third round so alireza is leading as
he's the only player that got two wins
um in the first three rounds then magnus
carlsen uh wesley so uh maxima grav
jordan van ferest and shah sha and
europe forest with four points uh shakir
madara with three yanni pomnishi and
linear dominguez uh with uh two uh also
even charged with two and the wesleyan
topalov with zero points he lost all
three of his games uh so hopefully it
will uh you know
get better for him in in further rounds
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it so here you can see that uh
even though even uh pretty much uh
neutralized alireza straight out of the
opening there wasn't really all that
much to play with the only thing alireza
had going for him was the doubled pawn
maybe
uh but uh yeah he just played much
faster even dropped on time and that was
enough for even uh
to make the the mistake in this crucial
position where he pushed the pawn to g3
uh too early so you can never
learn enough uh of the rook and games
it's simply an area that you you can
learn forever and you will never be a
master of it you you always be surprised
and you always uh you know find
positions that you can't solve and by
you cancel i mean when you are very low
on time so i study the end game it is
the most important uh uh part of chess
some would say the end game is chess
uh once again really hope you enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank john austin
michael higgins dominique alvarez gordon
mercer and san cotsolo for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until this finishes so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day